nft and cryptocurrency appears to be the
order of the day these days especially
since the covert 19 pandemic nearly
drove the entire wall to code digital
both appear to be a profitable markets
you have probably read stories about
people making hundreds of millions of
dollars using nfcs or headlines about
cryptocurrency values fluctuating and
even crashing as a result of a single
elon musk tree
if you're not familiar with these terms
it's understandable if you have wondered
if nfps and cryptocurrencies are the
same thing well they aren't
although there are some parallels
between nfts and cryptocurrencies they
are not the same thing
so hello everyone i'm shami and i
welcome you all to this new video of
simply learn on nfps versus crypto
before diving deep into the difference
between nft and cryptocurrency
let's first define what these two are
nft is an acronym for non-fungible
tokens
when it's unique and
can't be replaced with something else
something is said to be non-fungible
each nfp contains
distinguishable information like who
owns the digital asset and who sold it
making them distinct and easily
verifiable as it is impossible to forge
such a certificate
nfc basically creates a blockchain based
digital certificate for your digital
collectibles including games music art
and many more this certificate gives
your artwork a unique identity
on the other hand cryptocurrency is
defined as a virtual currency that
utilizes cryptography to secure and
verify transactions as well as regulate
and control the generation of new
currency units
it is decentralized and free from any
third-party
interference which means it is not
issued and controlled by any government
or central authority unlike other
payment systems that banks or
governments are handling
cryptocurrency charges almost no of very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
20.7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges or making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account or any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency
now that we know the basic concept of
both nft and cryptocurrency and
understood the underlying technology
let's move ahead and look into the
comparison parameters for nft versus
crypto
first is trading the process of the
trading in the crypto market
second is purpose
we will differentiate between them by
the purpose behind the concept
third is
volatility in this we will compare the
performance and a volatile nature in the
crypto market
and the fourth and the last one is users
and marketplaces in this we will look
into the difference between their users
as well as the marketplaces they're
actively used
trading
nfps are bought and traded online and
are managed in digital ledger therefore
they cannot be traded for one another
for example instead of purchasing a
physical photograph to hang on the wall
the buyer receives an original digital
file and he pays for it by money
whereas cryptocurrencies can be traded
or exchanged for each other with no loss
of their value
the peer-to-peer system which works
using blockchain technology enables
anyone to send and receive payments
through any form of digital money or
cryptocurrency
now coming to purpose
each non-functional token serves as a
form of authenticity certificate
indicating that a digital asset is
distinct and not interchangeable
due to the cryptographic principles that
characterize the blockchain and nft can
never be altered adjusted or stolen
cryptocurrency on the other hand like
traditional currencies such as the us
dollar is a medium of exchange designed
to exchange digital information and
solve the
difficulties of traditional currencies
by allowing for quick secure and
decentralized transactions as well as
the purchase and payment of goods and
services
coming to the next one
volatility
although both nfp and cryptocurrency
have unstable volatility nfps are
thought to be less volatile in
comparison to cryptocurrency
artists and traders alike have been
drawn to nfd because of its creative
artistic site on the other hand it may
deter individuals who find the task of
designing nfps excessively difficult
complicated or inconvenient
but cryptocurrencies in particular are
regarded as high risk investments as
crypto opponents and regulators have
frequently stated in their condemnation
of cryptocurrencies however
certain cryptocurrencies have been
created with the intention of being more
stable than others
and also high-risk comes with high
rewards
now coming to the users and marketplaces
nft is used for digital content gaming
items investment and collaterals domain
names and etc
whereas cryptocurrency is used for low
cost money transfers wealth management
ethical business practices and etc
currently the largest energy
marketplaces are readable openc and
foundation
on the other hand the largest crypto
marketplaces are binance coinbase kraken
and etoro
well now that we know the difference
between nft and cryptocurrency
let's discuss what's better between them
now if you're artistically inclined and
want to make money for your digital
artwork
and if these are a viable option the
market's creative artistic component has
enticed both artists and traders to
participate
on the other side although cryptos are
slightly unpredictable some
cryptocurrencies have been created to be
more stable than others these
cryptocurrencies are known as stable
coins
and the key advantage is that they have
lower volatility than other
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin or
ethereum
better and usd coin are two examples of
stable coins their worth is determined
by the us dollar's value
so how do you decide which of the two is
the better option
it is determined by the traders
motivation and readiness to take risk
so
this was all about nfp versus crypto do
let me know your thoughts on these
comparisons in the comment section
you have almost reached the end of this
video if i miss anything important do
let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on nhd
versus crypto and learn something new
from it if you like this video then
please do hit the like button thanks for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more updates and videos from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here